So when you look at the landscape now,
um,
you,
you're obviously in the running for a shot at the title.
Has anybody give you any indication of what you would have to do to get a shot
at Uzman or to be next in line?
Well,
the next one is,
is,
uh,
is 80.
Don't even mention his name on your show because I'm not going to make him
famous.
She's a fucking idiot,
you know,
but fight this guy and then go for the title.
That's what it is,
homey.
So you have to find somebody else.
Yeah.
What is his name?
Ryan with?
Oh,
Dolby.
No,
no,
no.
You don't want to say no,
I was trying to legacy on Edwards.
No,
no,
no.
He's just made that guy famous soup.
You made him famous a couple of weeks ago.
I know.
It's Oh sure man.
Who Shmenn.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
you're supposed to fight it.
Penn ask in July fucking doors.
You don't like him?
Not One bit really own being,
not as that was the fight was scheduled.
Um,
what's,
what's the problem with VAT answering?
He's that new wage,
you know,
and he's like a fucking 40 year old and a science teacher to want in a way.
Yes.
What age?
But he's like,
these new ones do is to just fucking talk.
Like,
just talk and talk and talk about everybody.
Shut the fuck up.
When you,
when,
when somebody sees your in person,
you're not that guy.
And like I said,
I'm,
I don't come from this technology world.
I come from like if you,
if you say like,
Yo fucking Joe,
you're fucking idiot,
what are you going to punch me in the face?
Or I better be ready for it.
You know,
I'm just not going around and disrespecting people.
I get taught respect because if not somebody who's gonna make you respect,
you know?
Right.
But these guys nowadays,
they grew up with these little things.
Nigga just say whatever the fuck they want.
Words carry weight.
Especially my kids can read your stupid comments.
You know,
my kids have access to the Internet now.
I just don't like them.
You know,
one incident I remind when could be one the title,
right?
And,
uh,
Ben immediately comes out,
um,
Khabib's Kryptonite,
I would smash him or something like that.
For starters,
you're 70 pounds,
you fucking moron.
He's a 55 pounds in.
You're not even in the UFC.
You know,
he's that type of guy and attention whore.
Look at me,
look at me.
I,
I don't even like his fighting style.
I like a lot of restaurant style because if that's what you did in your imposing
and when and awesome,
but when your sole purpose is just to hug somebody legs as hard as you can,
and then I,
I don't know what you think about the Ravi fine,
but he didn't win that fight in my eyes.
You know,
we won was not asleep several times.
We lost that fight several times.
I thought that rob was asleep for a second and then,
Ooh,
smart showed it to me and then I changed my mind.
And then herb dean came on and talked about and I changed my mind again because
herb dean was saying that what he was concerned with was the way the arm dropped
and that it was a cervical lock.
The,
essentially when you have a bulldog choke it puts,
puts a some serious leverage on your neck is like,
and he's seen guys go out from that and their whole body goes paralyzed and he
saw a guy,
uh,
where that happened to it and he came back his,
you've got us moving back again.
But for awhile it was pretty fucking scary.
So who's getting choked out?
You know,
by getting his neck pinched,
it was pinching down the nerve.
He was worried that that was happening with Robbie said the ways arm dropped.
He goes,
it wasn't normal and he goes at it and he gave me some serious concern.
Um,
Ben asked her and said that he let go of the choke a little bit when herb came
over to him cause he thought herb is going to stop it cause he thought Robert
was out and he thinks that during that time when he let go,
Robbie came back to life,
which could have happened.
I don't know,
it's hard for me to say,
but I feel like in herb dean situation,
I think he did the right thing because of the arm dropping.
Was fucking weird.
And the arm driving was a little weird.
Yeah,
but he wasn't.
Now,
I never seen nobody to go to seep doing this.
I've seen people go to sleep.
Ashley,
Evan Smith went to sleep with the thumbs up,
thumbs up.
But here's what the purpose of that made sense.
He goes,
was it the thumbs up because I want a thumbs up.
If someone looks at me,
I want this.
It's not,
is your arm down on that position?
He goes,
yeah,
but was it this?
Did he do this or it was his arm down.
I don't know.
Only Robbie knows whether or not he was out.
He says he wasn't.
So you have to also say he's in the middle of war.
Right.
So if it's up to me,
I want the Guy To go pee sign with the guy who's defending the choke with,
you know they did.
That was the other thing that herb said he didn't grab for the choke and he said
the natural defense would be to get,
get his hands on the,
on the hands and try to separate them.
He didn't do that.
He said,
that's Herb's natural defense.
Maybe Robbie,
cause he's seen this guy do it as a fucking thing.
You know,
maybe Romney can be put to sleep from.
They're just guys that are weird like that.
Certain positions they could go three minutes,
you're choking them and then they don't go to sleep.
Maybe Robbie's that guy.
All I know is he wasn't sleeping.
Yeah,
well that's what Robbie said.
Robbie said that he was waiting for Ben to tires,
arms out [inaudible] that's what he said.
He said that he felt the tie,
the squeeze,
the squeeze really tight,
but he's like,
I'll just let him gas his arms out here.
That was his thought.
Look,
I mean Michael Kessler said that when Kevin Lee got his back and they stopped
the fight before he went out,
he said,
I let my hands go cause I was concentrating on my neck.
I was just tightening up by neck and trying to to keep my blood flowing.
I think that one was a little different than it was over.
You're naked,
you know?
Yeah.
It was different that you're going to go to ship eventually and that one,
let a guy go to sleep like that one.
You should let a guy go to sleep and let him.
Yeah,
the thing happens.
You need to just wake them right up.
Hey,
you went to sleep?
No big.
Maybe the pee their pants,
whether they went to sleep,
no big deal.
It's certain net cracks.
We were just go,
oh no,
but that one's not going to put you in a weird trend and especially enough from
Ben's Ashman prob.
So your take is on all of this trash talking media hype shit that you see going
on now.
You don't like it?
I don't,
I don't.
I think,
uh,
I fast forward,
it's not like it's distasteful right now to a certain point,
but if you just forward
to the guys like me when I was 14 years old watching the sport,
now you're looking at the dues right now doing it.
You're going to grow up and think,
oh,
I've got to do the same shit.
I just got to fucking talk a shit lot of shit.
I don't really got to go to the gym that much.
She's got to have a banging,
lit social network account and I'm fucking Golden,
you know?
And we see it,
you know,
a sage Northcutt for example,
great town and stuff.
But um,
what he was getting paid out.
Did it make sense for a lot of the fighters?
You know,
why,
why was he getting paid so much?
Because of the social media is,
but as he really bringing in those people into the chairs and into the TV,
because you have a lot of lights,
you know,
so the things that I wonder,
not like to disagree with one of them,
but sometimes girls have like tremendous amount of followers,
you know.
Do those numbers translate to viewers on the TV or,
or like butts in seats or any of that?
Like I,
I would like to know,
you know,
and a lot of times when I've asked like people in the UFC and stuff,
they say no,
those numbers don't translate.
So what do they get more money?
You know,
I'm not talking about the girls get more money.
You know what I'm talking about guys that have like a social media presence that
are just getting more
money.
Money.
Just think it's Kinda translate certain amount.
No,
I'm sure it does.
Like guys like Colby Colby is gotta translate.
I mean he's,
he talks so much shit.
He,
you know,
gets people excited about the fights.
There's something to it.
I don't know,
I just,
I appreciate what you're saying though.
And I,
I look,
I appreciate the way one fc handles things cause they concentrate on just
fighters being honorable and fighting their best and find the best fighters they
can fight.
And they don't emphasize that shit talking at all.
They emphasize the martial arts aspect of I get it,
me and you don't like each other.
John Jones and DC.
I love it.
Cause you can feel these guys don't like each of you feel it.
Kill each other,
you know.
But to me everybody's doing it.
When Max Holloway fought Dustin,
there was none of that.
There was just two guys who were the best in their weight class.
I mean Max is the best hundred 45 pounds ever.
And Dustin Poirier is absolutely one of the best one in 55 pounders alive.
And they're going to go after it.
And it was on the floor,
two dogs.
It was beautiful.
It was a parking,
just biting them,
fighting chicken hands,
full respect before and after.
Yeah.
And I get a lot of people like they have that,
uh,
I hate using Jim going into the fight,
so they don't want to shake hands.
Like,
fuck you,
I don't like you.
You know?
But when,
when they're giving so much attention to that WWF stuff and pushing you to the
forefront,
that I don't mean it like,
you know,
and just to think that the kids watching it are going to be even worse.
They're going to do it to the next power.
You know?